[Musique]
l'industrie légale du cannabis se
prépare à prendre son envol faut créer
un nouveau système
justin trudeau a promis de porter un
coup dur aux organisations criminelles
le régime actuel ne fonctionne pas pour
protéger nos enfants
ça protège pas à nos communautés de
l'impact des crimes organisés
mais à une semaine de la légalisation le
marché noir n'a pas dit son dernier mot
radio-canada a pu facilement repéré au
moins une dizaine de sites web illicites
de vente de cannabis et produits dérivés
friandises contenant du thc résine et
concentré de cannabis sont accessibles à
tous les produits sont inégaux mais les
sites ont une apparence légitime et
professionnels de quoi confondre les
internautes il ya des éléments dans les
sites internet qui nous font penser que
c'est tout à fait légal par exemple on a
voulu produit par postes canada on
charge même la taxe de vente
ce qui est totalement illégal
radio-canada a fait le test auprès d'un
site copie d'une pièce d'identité
virement bancaire électronique il tour
est joué on a reçu notre colis en moins
de 48 heures via postes canada
ça nous est expédiée via vancouver pour
l'ouvrir star ballet de manière très
professionnelle sous vide pour masquer
les odeurs
voici ce que nous avons obtenu pour
environ 100 dollars des friandises des
produits concentrés et du cannabis séché
à ces magnifiques c'est impeccable c'est
du bon marketing
on voit qu'il ya aucune mise en garde
aucune mise en garde pour un produit qui
a l'air agréable pour les enfants c'est
passé des juges de différentes couleurs
alors ceux-là c'est un danger public de
laisser ça quelque part dans une maison
le responsable du dossier cannabis pour
le gouvernement trudeau est très
préoccupé il rappelle que ces produits
dérivés sont potentiellement dangereux
parce qu'ils échappent à tout contrôle
de qualité
selon lui c'est aux forces policières
d'intervenir mais la grc ne semble pas
en faire une priorité
expliquant plus tôt qu'elle concentre
ses ressources et ses activités pour
contrer les menaces criminelles les plus
importantes qui pèsent sur les canadiens
l'opposition officielle croit qu'ottawa
a l'obligation d'agir bel air a dit que
cela ne va pas porter plainte aux
policiers mais moi je dis ça vous le
gouvernement de prendre votre
responsabilité est d'aider les
progiciels plus rapidement bruxelles
les libéraux ont promis de réglementer
les produits comestibles et dérivés du
cannabis
d'ici un an et tant qu'ils seront
interdits sur le marché légal des
criminels semble déterminé à en profiter
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa